[Musique]
bonjour Jacques Martial bonjour merci de
venir sur ce plateau entre septembre et
jusqu'à la semaine dernière vous avez
joué Cahier d'un retour au pays natal
texte des mes Césaire sur la scène de la
Cartoucherie à Paris texte d'une
puissance inouïe on va en parler
longuement comment est né ce spectacle
ce spectacle est né du désir de faire
entendre cette parole et plus que du
désir je crois de l'urgence de faire
entendre aujourd'hui cette parole cette
pensée cette vision du monde et de
l'humanité qui est celle d'aimer
césaires d'entrée de jeu on écoute un
extrait de ce spectacle on se retrouve
tout juste après
dans ma mémoire sont des lagunes
elles sont couvertes de tête de mort
S
une autre petite maison
qui sent très mauvais
dans une rue très étroite
une maison
minuscule qui abrite dans ses entrailles
de bois pourris des dizaines de rats et
la turbulence de mes ci frères et sœurs
une petite maison cruelle dans
l'intransigeance affole nos fins de moi
et mon père
fantasque
grignoter d'une seule misère ce n'est
jamais su laquelle
qu'une imprévisible sorcellerie assoupi
en mélancolique tendresse ou exalte en
haute flamme de colère
et ma mère
dans les jambes pour notre fin à la
simple [__]
au bout du petit matin on connaît
l'incipit de ce texte Jacques Martial la
première version du Cahier d'un retour
au pays natal remonte à 1939 et mes
Césaire à 26 ans est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler l'histoire le contexte
également oui on est en
1939 c'est quelque chose qui résonne
dans la mémoire collective du monde
entier puisque en étant juin 1939 et
quelques semaines plus tard le monde va
basculer dans la très grande catastrophe
le monde va entrer dans une guerre
terrible ou l'humain va les valeurs
d'humanité vont disparaître ou vous
sembler disparaître pour en tout cas
pour longtemps et
aimé césaires jeune homme arrivait
quelques années plus tôt à Paris de sa
Martinique natale va pousser ce cri ce
cri de ralliement d'une humanité qui
appelle au respect mutuel et ce cri il
initie il l'encre dans l'histoire des
peuples noirs des peuples
des Antilles d'abord des entiers d'où il
vient et puis plus largement des peuples
noirs il a
inventé avec son ami Léopold Sédar
Senghor et
les rencontres Damas le concept de
négritude qui appelle à une
reconnaissance à un respect à une
reconnaissance naître à nouveau ensemble
être ensemble penser collectivement la
la
diversité culturelle déjà en somme il
dit avec des mots puissants l'horreur de
l'esclavage de la domination de l'homme
par l'homme l'horreur d'une époque ou
l'Europe fait la loi partout avec ses
empires comment ce texte a-t-il reçu à
ce moment là
à au moment de sa parution alors il y a
des personnes commanderait breton qui
vont être immédiatement qui vont
comprendre la puissance visionnaire de
de ce texte et puis la beauté tout
simplement parce qu'on a affaire à un
poète immense qui qui s'ouvre enfin qui
se découvre au reste du monde donc il y
a tout ce pan de la de la Société des
intellectuels qui vont qui vont le
comprendre et puis bien sûr qui
comprendront l'inverse qui vont être
agressés par la puissance la violence de
ce que dénonce ce texte qui vont
l'interpréter pour certains à l'envers
dire non c'est un texte raciste parce
qu'il remet tout simplement en cause en
question
un équilibre qu'on pense
éternelle des rapports de force entre le
Nord et le Sud entre les différentes
communautés parce qu'à l'époque les
thèses racistes fleurissent le compte de
gobino promet la soi-disant inégalité
des
humaines face à lui là ici en ténor
Firmin qui défendra brillamment la thèse
inverse autre élément non négligeable
dans dans ce spectacle et dans ce texte
il y a également l'antisémitisme
oui absolument
aimer ses airs ne plaît pas seulement
pour les peuples de race noire il dit je
serai un homme juif un homme cash un
homme un doux de Calcutta un homme de
Harlem il parle pour l'humanité et
d'ailleurs c'est ainsi aujourd'hui que
le texte et je crois perçu compris c'est
que quand il dit ma bouche sera la
bouche des malheurs qui n'ont point de
bouche il parle en fait de tous les
opprimés et il parle pour en tout cas au
nom de pour donner une voix pour donner
à entendre une parole
et celle des opprimés de celle qui
justement d'habitude n'ont pas voient au
chapitre ce spectacle voulait jouer
pendant une heure et quinze minutes il y
a pas d'entracte peine quelques éléments
de musique et de son et tout ça mais
globalement il y a pas on vous voit en
train de suer à un moment donné c'est un
défi sportif non commercial c'est très
physique le théâtre de toute façon c'est
un engagement physique et puis
là je dois je peux dire que ça aide à la
même à l'esthétique de du spectacle mais
c'est un engagement physique de toute
façon le théâtre ce n'est pas une
promenade de santé forcément ça peut
l'être ça l'est aussi mais ça demande
pour l'artiste en tout cas à ce niveau
de texte et d'exigence d'exigence de
texte il faut il faut y aller quoi il
faut mouiller la chemise on repart
justement sur la scène de la de la
Cartoucherie on écoute un deuxième
extrait de votre spectacle
dans ma mémoire sont des lagunes
elles sont couvertes de tête de mort
elles ne sont pas couvertes de nénuphars
sont des lacunes sur leur rive ne sont
pas étendues des pagnes de femmes
ma mémoire
est entourée de sang
ma mémoire à sa ceinture de cadavre
les [__] sont tous les mêmes je vous
le dis
les filles tous les vices
l'odeur du [__] ça fait pousser la
canne
dans votre bouche Jacques Martial il
était un ardent défenseur de ce qu'on
pouvait appeler la pensée des coloniale
dénoncer aujourd'hui par certains
conservateurs comme wolvant du mouvement
wok en gros aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
Aimé Césaire dirait de l'époque
opposé à ceux qui ne comprennent pas
l'importance de changer les deux de
changer les les les paradigmes de la
pensée c'est à dire que ceux qui veulent
revenir autant d'avant let's make
l'époque great again sur le c'est-à-dire
comme dans les années 50 là où la
différence la diversité et finalement la
le rapprochement entre les peuples est
indispensable ceux qui remettent selon
en question n'ont toujours pas compris
n'ont toujours pas compris les leçons
que de réduire nous enseigner l'époque
où par essai Cahier d'un retour au pays
data 1939 c'est la guerre le monde va
entrer dans la catastrophe et
aujourd'hui il y a des personnes qui
sont nostalgiques de cette époque où il
se pensait
supérieur à d'autres mais on ne peut pas
construire du collectif on ne peut pas
selon moi construire de de
l'envie d'être ensemble de construire
ensemble un avenir si on prétend d'or
d'emblée qu'il y a des inférieurs et des
supérieurs ça ne marche pas comme ça
s'il y a des personnes des individus qui
participent d'un projet collectif et
c'est cela qu'il faut construire c'est
ce que propose et mes sœurs en disant
nous sommes debout mon pays et moi et
c'est un grand nous embrasse nous
jusqu'au nous furieux qu'il écrit avec
une majuscule on a besoin de se
collectif et prétendre d'entrer de jeu
que c'est avec en imposant
des différences de valeurs
les plus grands les moins grands les que
l'on va que l'on va réussir c'est un non
sens ça ne fonctionnera pas ce spectacle
a été joué un peu partout dans le monde
en anglais et en français alors ce que
j'ai relevé c'est bizarrement c'est
peut-être en France qu'il a été le moins
joué c'est
un peu c'est un peu vrai c'est un peu
vrai mais c'est parce que on me le
demande de beaucoup à l'international
Césaire et quelqu'un de
non seulement connu mais mais qui
inspire aujourd'hui les les les peuples
c'est les pays je l'ai découvert
j'ai été surpris et très heureux de cela
mais la France arrive d'ailleurs j'étais
oui à la Cartoucherie au théâtre de
l'épée de bois à Vincennes donc nous
sommes déjà à Paris c'est un c'est un
vrai bonheur de voir le spectacle porter
si bien compris aussi par la compagnie
de la comédie noire que vous avez fondé
il y a 22 ans l'objectif à l'époque
c'était de favoriser la représentation
des personnes du tissu des minorités
dans le monde de la création du cinéma
du théâtre etc quel on est le bilan
aujourd'hui
la compagnie elle-même oui nous nous
avons travaillé mais alors moi j'ai une
intermittence je me suis un peu arrêté
dans ma créativité parce que j'ai eu
pendant de nombreuses années des
fonctions très officielles j'ai été
président du Parc de la Villette j'ai
dirigé le mémorialat de Guadeloupe donc
des très grandes institutions qui ont
ralenti mon processus de de d'artiste de
création et de créativité cependant
ce qui est ce qui a initié
la création de la comédie noire c'est
faire l'absence de visibilité de la de
des artistes de la
diversité culturelle sur les scènes
devant les écrans aujourd'hui je vois
qu'il y a que des progrès des progrès
qui sont quand je regarde les écrans je
dis tiens je me regarde je me dis tiens
le
notre société a bougé ce n'était pas
fini on voit bien qu'il y a des forces
au contraire qui voudraient dès qu'on
relâche raie
la pression revenir à ce temps d'avant
dont on parlait et c'est là où c'est
vers le dit la carte du printemps est
toujours à refaire c'est à dire on ne
lâche rien il faut rester vigilant et
continuer de d'avancer vers nos idéaux
merci beaucoup Jacques Martial d'être
venu jusqu'à nous alors peut-être la
plus jeune ne vous auront pas remarqué
et vous avez joué dans 19 saisons
d'avaro sur TF1 merci beaucoup c'était
l'invité de Paris direct Jacques Martial
sur la scène de la Cartoucherie à
Vincennes Cahier d'un retour au pays
natal de c'était notre invité
l'information internationales les
françaises continuent sur France 24 et
sur France 24